The true crime stuff,
I think it has good points and bad
points,
good points because it is literally
saving people's lives when you're
talking about cases where you have
innocent people sentenced to death,
you have innocent people are doing life
without parole and it happens way more
often than people have any idea.
Uh,
a guy named Bryan Stevenson who works
with the southern poverty law center,
I was talking to him one time and he
said that they now estimate that maybe
as many as one out of every 10 people
executed are innocent.
Now if one out of every 10 planes
crashed,
nobody would fly anymore.
Everybody would demand that something be
done before they got on another plane.
But most people don't know anyone that
are and they're not connected in any way
to the death penalty.
So it's sort of just being swept under
the rug and a lot of ways.
So the true crime stuff is bringing
stuff like that into mainstream
attention.
Uh,
it's saving people's lives.
On the other hand,
you have the other stuff,
the really tawdry,
and I can't think of a case right off
the top of my head,
but you know,
just people like to sort of wallow in
the darkness of humanity a little bit,
you know,
say people who want to read stuff about
Richard Ramirez,
the night stalker guy,
you know,
stuff like that,
that sort of goes the other route.
You know,
I think when you,
whatever you focus on is going to sort
of dictate the direction that your life
moves.
If you focus on things that inspire you,
that uplift you,
that raise you up,
you're going to be a happier person.
If you're focusing more on the basest
just you know,
bottom dregs of human activity,
then you're probably not going to be a
very happy person.
You know,
it's gonna manifest in depression and
despair and,
uh,
things like that.
So,
you know,
I see the good points of
true crime and I see the bad points of
true crime.
For me personally,
I tend to stay away from it.
I honestly have not even seen the
paradise lost documentaries.
I tried to watch,
watch them,
I made it through 15 to 20 minutes of
the first one and I could understand why
it had such a big impact on people
because when I was watching it,
it felt like being in the courtroom,
it was like experiencing it again.
And for me that was the last thing in
the world that I wanted.
That was,
it ate up 20 years of my life.
So the last thing I wanted to do is go
back there at the same time.
I'm grateful that so many other people
did watch it and were affected by it and
came to our aid because it saved my
life.
But that doesn't mean I want to watch
it.
The hardest parts of being in prison,
the worst parts to deal with or just the
sheer brutality of it.
You know,
there were times when I was beaten so
bad that I started to piss blood.
Uh,
you know,
they're not going to spend a lot of time
and money and energy taking care of
someone,
plan on killing.
So it's not like you're going to see a
real doctor or a real dentist,
you know,
there's,
at one point I'd been hit in the face so
many times by prison guards that had
caused a lot of nerve damage in my
teeth.
So I was in horrendous pain.
Your choices are live in pain or let
them pull your teeth out.
I didn't want them to pull my teeth out.
So I had to find techniques that would
allow me to cope with the physical pain.
That was probably the biggest thing that
kept pushing me forward to learn more
and more and more about magic because I
had to find ways just to survive.
Um,
Magik spelled with a k at the end.
They may gick.
Uh,
the reason it has a k is to
differentiate it from sleight of hand.
You know,
a song assistance in half,
pulling rabbits out of hats,
things like that.
For the entire point of high magic.
It is a path that leads to the same
things at eastern traditions refer to as
enlightenment,
which is the disillusion of the self.
The form that I practice a derived for
the most part from the late 18 hundreds
in London,
you had a group of people,
uh,
they called themselves a hermetic order
of the Golden Dawn.
Some really intelligent people.
Uh,
the poet web gates was a member.
What they set out to do was look into
all religious traditions in the world
and get to just the practices,
you strip away the dogma,
the belief systems,
things like that and get to just the
practices and they wanted to figure out
what works,
why it works,
how it works,
and how we can make it work better.
And it's ideally suited to people in the
West because it uses,
you know,
like I was saying,
Christian Judaic things of that nature.
Iconography.
So it's things that are really deeply
ingrained in our psyches already.
You know.
Um,
when I was in prison,
I actually also received ordination in
the Rinzai Zen tradition of Japanese
Buddhism.
It was a tradition that used to train
the Samurai in ancient Japan.
So I sat zen meditation for years and I
still feel like I got more out of
ceremonial magic and month than I did
zen in years.
Just because it is more it.
It deals with things that are more
deeply ingrained in the western psyche
than eastern traditions.
Do you know,
think of it,
for example,
think of yourself as a cup of water.
Now,
if you just leave a cup of water sitting
somewhere for a long period of time,
it starts to stagnate.
It's going to accumulate debris.
Maybe it's even going to start to clot
up over a long enough period of time.
What ceremonial magic tries to do is
invoke certain energies into your
system.
Now,
if you were to take that cup of water
that's stagnant,
Cup of water and just hold it under a
running faucet and just let it run until
it spills over the ram and hold it there
and just let it spill and spill and
spill.
Eventually what's gonna happen is all
that debris,
all that stagnation is going to be
washed out.
The same thing happens to us on an
energetic level.
One,
we're constantly invoking all these
energies.
The reason they're at planetary
astrological,
elemental,
they're still all variations of a type
of energy that we have a name for an
every single culture in the world except
ours.
You know,
for example,
the Chinese call it CCI,
the Japanese call it key,
the Hebrews call it rock,
the Indians call it Prada.
In the West,
we're the only ones who don't really
have a name for it.
So that's Kinda why I prefer just the
generic term of energy.
The thing I always tell people about
magic is you're already doing it.
You just don't realize it yet and you're
usually doing it to your own detriment.
You know,
for example,
whenever we're thinking of health,
we don't usually hold a picture in our
heads of ourselves as being vibrant and
healthy and whole.
Instead we're thinking things like,
oh,
I hope I don't get the flu this year.
The neighbors got it.
Everybody in the neighborhood's got it.
So I'm probably gonna come down with it
too.
Every time I get it,
I usually get it twice as bad as
everyone else.
It lasts twice as long.
So when we're doing that,
what we're actually doing is holding a
visualization of ourselves as being sick
in our heads.
You know,
we're putting energy into that.
There's a phrase now,
and I can't remember who came up with
it,
but they say where attention goes,
energy flows,
whatever you're focusing on,
you are giving energy to.
So a lot of magic is about training
yourself to focus on what you want
instead of what you don't want.
And that's what we call thought forms.
The more you can focus on what it is
you're wanting,
the more energy you're putting onto it,
which means the more powerful thought
form you're creating.
You know,
when it comes to resiliency,
I think the thing that saved my life in
there was I found what I was supposed to
be doing in life.
As crazy as it sounds,
there were entire weeks would go by when
I didn't even think about the fact that
I was in prison because I was so focused
on magic.
You know,
people even now,
people will come up to me.
People who have been through horrible
things,
people who suffer from depression of
some sort and they say,
you know what got you through that,
what would bring you through these
things?
And the honest answer is there are only
two causes of depression.
One is a chemical imbalance,
in which case the only thing that's
going to correct it is medication,
something of that nature to correct a
physical problem,
the other cause in one way or another is
you're not doing what in magic we call
your will in Buddhism,
they call it Dharma.
It's the thing that you're put here to
do.
Nature.
The Universe is not going to waste a lot
of energy making duplicate people,
making cookie cutter people.
We're all here for a specific purpose
and your purpose may be similar to
someone else's,
but it's not gonna be exactly the same
because like I said,
the universe isn't going to waste that
energy.
The cause of happiness and the cause of
depression is figuring out what you're
supposed to be doing in this life and
then dedicating yourself to it 100
percent to the best of your ability.
From me,
that was doing magic when I started to
devote every minute of every day to
doing magic while I was in prison.
By the time I got out,
I was doing it under eight hours a day.
Once I started to do that,
everything else took a backseat.
You know,
I,
I still went through horrendous things,
you know,
like beatings or starvation or whatever
it was,
but you know,
once it's done I get right back up and I
go to doing magic because it was what I
loved.
It was,
you know,
when I started to figure out what was
possible because of this and how it was
affecting me on a mental level,
on an emotional level,
on a physical level,
I was so excited about it that
everything else just faded into the
background and I was happy even in
prison,
even on death row for huge chunks of
time,
I was happy because I was doing what I
was supposed to be doing in the world.
And still to this day,
you know,
the example I always give to people is
Michelangelo.
Whenever they asked him,
how do you create these sculptures,
he said,
well,
I just look at the block of marble and I
carved away anything that's not part of
the figure.
That's where happiness comes from.
You look at your life and you start
carving away anything that's not
pertinent to your life's mission.
So for me,
for example,
I don't go to parties.
I don't go to clubs,
I don't go to concerts.
I don't Chit Chat.
For me,
anything that is not directly connected
to magic,
I have gradually carved away from my
life and it has made me a much,
much happier person.
Social media.
I honestly now I try to stay away from
it as much as I possibly can.
I think it can be useful for really down
to earth practical things like letting
people know,
you know,
for example,
I'll use it to let people know where I'm
going to be doing a meditation class,
things of that nature.
But at the same time I think it is
incredibly detrimental as far as what
we're putting our energy into.
You know,
part of what magic is,
is containing our energy containing are
cheap because we disperse it constantly.
We disperse it in everything we think
about everything we talk about and you
know,
I,
I saw a study come out about a week or
so ago where scientists were pretty much
saying we are now practically one
generation away from the extinction of
humanity due to climate change,
global warming,
all this sort of stuff.
Yet the only thing that people were
talking about on social media was Kanye
west at the White House.
So it really can be detrimental to our
development if you let you know the
meaningless things or if you just spend
hours and hours a day combing through,
you know,
instagram photos of people taking
selfies,
things of that.
I think you really have to be careful
with everything you consume and not just
in a physical way,
but mentally and emotionally as well as
well as everything that you put out.
I always try to be as mindful as I
possibly can about,
you know,
whatever I take in through the Internet
and whatever I put out through the
Internet.